foreign
welcome to the Ramsey Show
better than I deserve what's up
um yeah I'm just calling I am a physical
therapist here in St Louis I've been out
of school for about a year now but I've
been in a Residency program so I've been
able to defer my loans and last night I
really sat down and figured out that I
need to start tackling these things
um but got about 112 000 in my name from
undergrad and also from graduate PC
school and then my parents also have
about a hundred thousand in their name
that they took out to help me get
through undergrad so I'm just kind of
curious the best way to tackle these and
get out of debt as quickly as possible
is this your only debt or do you have
other types of debt to go along with it
this is the only dead I have okay well
what I would do if I were in your shoes
is a I'm glad that you're looking at
this and going hey I got to pay this off
I can't wait around for somebody else to
do it for me so that's good
um a lot of times these loans they're
broken into lots of smaller loans are
yours are they like that Yes mine are
yeah I've got uh all together they're
about 20 just small loans okay so
assuming that the parent Plus Loans were
like it was decided that you're the one
paying them back I'm assuming that's the
case right even though they took the
loan out
um well we haven't really had that
conversation yet so that's something
that I need to do with my parents um so
we have 112 000 are all in my name and
then the hundred thousand of Parent Plus
Loans what makes you think you're liable
for The Parent Plus Loans did they you
didn't have a discussion when you took
them out they said we'll take these out
but you've got to pay them that wasn't a
conversation
the conversation that we've had is we'll
help you with this but we haven't had a
fully sit-down conversation to decide
what exactly does that mean so that is
very that is like top right your parents
are not wealthy
not necessarily middle class
um they do they do okay I wasn't putting
them down I'm just if they got 10
million dollars in the bank they
wouldn't have done this well some people
also think that me helping you is Alco
sign since you can't sign on your own so
they might have just thought by
co-signing that was it but there's a lot
of money on the table here so I would
have that conversation and find out
um Ali did you finish residency yet
yes I said I said now so what do you
make now start 80. so
let's see this past year during my
resume no what will you make this year
80 this coming year this year I'll make
71.71 okay plus you think you can pick
up some OT uh if not with that firm with
uh whatever uh emergency room or
whatever right
yeah so we can we can use this degree to
earn another 20 and you work your tail
end off right
yeah I would say so I know so I've done
it that's the case done a bunch with pts
yeah well that's good I would just list
these debts smallest to largest I would
you know you gotta have this
conversation with your parents at the
same time your name is on is your name
on it at all no not on Parent Plus Loans
okay so I would start with the 112 yes
and I would list those from smallest to
largest I'd just go crazy go ham on
those and then this Parent PLUS thing
here's the thing their name is on it
your name is not on it so
you need to speak with them it's not
going to blow up your credit if this is
kind of an ongoing you know conversation
it's not going to stop you from doing
what you need to do
um but that's going to be tough Dave
because they might have interpreted two
different sizes whatever comes out I
mean if you guys if you decide you're
going to pay it then you got 212 000 and
you make 90 with overtime and extra jobs
and you're single and you live on
nothing like a graduate student and so
we throw 50 a year at it in four years
you're done yeah or in two or in two
years you're done if Mom and Dad pick up
the parent plus but you're probably
picking up at least some of it it sounds
like in this conversation
I I would guess so yeah you don't have a
legal obligation I don't really feel
yeah both of you should have your tail
kicked for not having a clear
understanding before you take out a
hundred thousand dollars worth of loans
and don't know how they're going to get
paid but now that that's done you now
you got to get drive to Clarity and
decide what you're going to do or what
you should do technically legally you
owe nothing I'd at least try to go 50 50
though I feel like I have no idea what
these people decided they were going to
do and so I'm not letting her or them
off the hook so um yeah y'all gotta get
in there and figure that part out and I
just but but either way Jade's right
your 112 is first you do not pay on The
Parent Plus Loans
um they at least get to pay the payments
until you clear the 112. that's their
part of the problem anyway yeah and then
after that if you decide you're going to
take it on we'll do that or something I
don't know I'm just you're gonna have to
make this up as you go because you
didn't do it on the front end
um this is how people end up not
speaking to each other that's saying
don't let it
out of money but I wouldn't let it come
between
the relationship I mean that sucks if
she has to be the one to well carry that
okay yeah you're right you're right but
either way we just got to work through
it and the 112 is first you live on
beans and rice rice and beans no life no
you don't get to go on vacation yes you
take every time someone offers you any
kind of overtime with your PT any kind
of extra PT jobs anywhere emergency room
anything you can do that's legal and
moral go do it and make money no eating
out no vacations you have made a mess
girl and you got to clean it up this is
the formula for getting out that's the
bad news the good news is it'll actually
work and you'll be debt free in around
three years if you go Whole Hog on this
get after it get after it that's how you
do it